now let's change gears gonna put the
Pokemon aside because today a new
overwatch character was announced yes
yes rumored for months as it's some sort
of sniper person Anna was revealed today
and we are going to go through her
abilities we're going to talk about the
trailer break it down I got to play her
a little bit earlier today and we're
gonna go for it but first let's talk
about initial impressions on ax she look
cool what do you guys think now let any
time you have another support class so
as someone who mains mercy like support
is my favorite way to play in giving you
another option to be a healer and a
healer and a really I think unique way
like I think it's really exciting it
seems much more difficult but the I'm
kind of excited by the challenge of cuz
I'm not a great damage dealing sniper
but to be able to be a healing sniper
like I think that seems like a lot of
fun I was just playing on a public test
realm right now and it was like a 7,000
person cue to get into like it only took
me like half an hour and all the matches
are all five Anna's verses 5 and I was
gonna say yes on the two matches that I
played just before coming in here like
my team was all Anna's and the other
team was actually taking it seriously
and they were yes enabling it to ya they
were just handing it to us right and it
didn't feel like it was supposed to be
that way like I would assume everyone
right now because it's just come out
just want to try it out just want to try
it Anna right but no like those seat
those guys weren't um what what I like
about her is yet they're healing shots
and her damaging shots are basically the
same thing like you don't have to switch
a weapon unit to switch let you have to
don't have to go into an old fire mode
yeah so I'm sort of like you I'm not a
great sniper but i think you know if
you're shooting and you just happen to
accidentally shoot one of your you know
your teammates it's still a benefit
right you don't always need to try you
know go for that you know super accurate
shot an opponent you know if you're in
there and you're in the fray you can
sort of do it but have you played it yet
yes so Tay and I were just live
streaming it earlier and so I got to
play as on a bunch and it is it's an
interesting sensation to get your head
around because your sniper but everyone
is a target not just enemies obviously
your eye is going to graduate is you're
going to be is going to look
for the red outlines you want to be
doing damage and the way she does damage
is a you know the shot hits and then
there's a little bit of damage over time
so it's like the main hit a little you
get those little ticks that indicate
you're doing some sort of sustained
damage is the healing also healing over
time yes the healing shots in the same
way you hit your ally and it'll heal and
then heal a little bit more and then
that's it but training yourself to look
for your allies and to try to shoot them
and maybe even shoot them first is what
took me some adjustment and it will
probably only take a few matches for you
to do it but it's it's a strange
sensation you know you are you're
targeting it's your targeting equally
with the same ability allies and enemies
you know with zenyatta for example
you're shooting at enemies but you're
also discord and harmony and you're
targeting both you know like this kind
of switching your mindset between
targets was really interesting and
pretty cool I know it's early days but
do you feel you have to be closer to the
action playing Anna than you would be I
was with it with another sniper class
well when you're playing five Anna's
someone needs to push the pace uh but I
do think that you don't you do have to
be a little closer her mobility she does
not have a mobility move yeah so it's
really weird for a sniper there's no
clamber like Hanzo there's no grapple
like Widowmaker so she's gotta walk up
the stairs to the balcony like anybody
else or you know have may give her a
boost on the wall so you do i do feel
like i tend to be with the team a little
more and that's also because i mean
quite frankly it's easier to blast your
teammates with a healing burst when
they're pretty close to you and it seems
like her other abilities sort of like
force you to be a bit closer right like
her sleep dot and that grenade that she
throws as well so let's talk about the
grenade this is uh it she throws it in a
fairly straight line it's us and it
covers quite a bit of distance so it's
not you know there's not as much arc on
it there's it's something that you can
definitely project onto someone from a
while away it almost feels like Farrah's
sort of like move back a burst attack
thing that grenade you know bursts in
does an area effect if an enemy's caught
in it which is quite small though it's
pretty small you
def you usually want to go for a direct
hit yeah and the effect on an enemy is
they get this like purple outline around
their health bar and they cannot be
healed any healing to them stops so you
see in the trailer it interrupts a road
hog you know if I mercy or Lucy owes
around they're not getting healed also
it does a little bit of damage over time
which you know while if it's on someone
like a diva it's not really gonna move
the needle much but if you have like
landed a shot or two on a support or
someone of lower health and you tag them
with that grenade you can kill them
outright so that goodnight is an area
effect right yeah it's in an area it
doesn't have to hit necessarily like I
can hit the ground in front of you yep
and it'll do an area but it will only
affect one character or everyone within
that radius I think that it will affect
it will affect everyone within that rate
ok so it will that's enemies and allies
alike because it also does healing not
only will it heal ally and your allies
but it will also increase temp early
increase any healing that's being done
to them so it's definitely you know
helps increase allies survivability on a
push also your own survivability if
you're running away you can kind of use
it liked or Jones armor when you throw
that down in a panic to like re Bri up
yourself so those to the grenade and the
gun hmm work both on allies and enemies
and then as you mentioned Randy to sleep
dart which is a tricky one because it
knocks you out and you watch them fall
on their back and actually I think we're
gonna try to get together a compilation
of sleeping heroes because zenyatta for
example when he's sleeping his legs are
just all the way out like he sprawled
out on the ground and diva when you put
her to sleep you just put her mech to
sleep and so she's inside the mech like
super frustrated that it won't move like
making this real pouty face and like
jamming of the controls but this is a
this is not like rinehart's earth
shatter which knocks you down for a set
amount of time if you're if you put
someone to sleep and then you shoot them
they wake up immediately yeah that's
what I couldn't figure out in my two
games because it seemed like sometimes
they'd stay there for a while mm-hmm
sometimes it get up straight away and I
didn't know whether it was a time thing
or a damaged thing but it's is it just
as soon as you get hit yes you wake up
doesn't matter the damage doesn't matter
the damage you could go over and punch
them in the face for
paltry amount of damage to wake them up
which is kind of a funny troll move now
that think about it so it's more an
escapement eva as opposed to offensive
maneuver then right uh it is it's an
escape maneuver it's also a shut down
the alt maneuver I put a Reaper to sleep
while he was down that's death
blossoming cool but there's a caveat
there because if they put again G to
sleep who had just activated his dragon
blade when Genji woke up the dragon
blade was in full effect oh so that
meter was on pause so you can't really
like burn someone's alt off you're in
that in that way but it's also great for
like just holding someone off on a
charge like say you know a tank is
coming in to support or a healer or
something that's a great way to sort of
crowd control and finally her ult mmm
and this is the one that has a potential
I think to do a lot of lot of weird
combos because what you do is it's you
know once it's available you all your
allies that you see will have a queue
over them like Zara is projected barrier
you don't have to aim it at someone
specifically you just have to tap the
button when the reticle is over them and
it charges it increases the damage they
do decreases the grid damage they take
and increases their movements code so
you can imagine what that does to a
Reinhardt charging on to a point right
and they show that in the trailer think
about what that does for a May mmm may
is all of a sudden taking taking a lot
of damage no problem spray in everybody
moving around real quick she can like it
like really increases how disruptive she
can be because as we all know getting
hosed by am a is a very unpleasant
experience now imagine she's like
scurrying around it juiced up speeds
doing that to your whole team maybe
she's not freezing anyone in particular
but she's still wreaking havoc so who
else I mean who else would be good on
that we saw a zenyatta do that and all
of a sudden zenyatta who was recently
buffed to have a little bit more shields
is a little tougher and he's slinging
these you knows discord orbs and
shredding people up hmm like in the two
matches I played it was mainly using a
rye not so you know you can you could
immediately see
Ryan how I was just going nuts he was
just going right in the middle of
everything and just trying to go crazy
once he did you know charged straight
off a cliff so that was fun um and also
like Winston as well right I mean like a
supercharged Winston using his alt you
know moving around that you know even
faster speed you know I think could be
super dangerous as well but yeah you're
right it opens up a lot of possible
possibilities for like you know there's
there's huge condos and even if and when
they're charging you can still be
shooting them they're still taking
damage but if you're shooting them then
you're healing them each time you can
hit them with your grenade to keep them
healed yep so that it feels like there's
more of a like a chaining effect
possible which is kind of this unique
from you know other heroes yes to the
way they support so it definitely feels
distinct and it's a very unique
character right like her move said so
and I think it'll take a while for
people to actually figure out the best
use case for her but right now you know
like I don't think I'd be using her
though just because it's still I think
she's still a fairly high skill
character definitely in order to you to
utilize properly um so I know you were
you're a HeLa mostly it she's still
fairly new in the in the game of like
you guys haven't had a chance to put
together a real team because everybody
just wants to try or try out do you feel
like her abilities might be a little
overpowered like reading about it it
seemed like whoa that's a lot everybody
says that but like any time a new
character is introduced to a game like
this people automatically sort of show
more this this this new characters so
Opie yeah and it takes the community a
little while to actually figure out you
know like all the best strategies to the
counters and stuff I mean you know a
Reaper got up next to me and it's over
it's not problem you know so I do think
the squishy support nature of her
character will help counterbalance that
Miss mobility yeah yeah the mobility
seems like it really keeps her in check
yeah if you folks want to try Anna out
for yourself and you've got overwatch on
the pc all you got to do is go change
your region setting in battle net to PTR
you'll see it right there and then do
the install it prompts you to do and
you'll be able to get in there try out
the new hero for yourself and see what
you think be sure to let us know on
Twitter and in
comments what you think of Anna you
overwatch hero